les policiers escortent le rédacteur en
chef de stand news à l'extérieur de
l'immeuble qui abrite le site web pro
démocratie puisse effectué des
perquisitions dans les locaux de la
publication les autorités accusent ces
responsables d'encourager la sédition
d'avoir publié des articles incitant au
mépris du gouvernement kong est le
number one man show arthur dont dix
pages ne soyez pas biaisé lancé aux
gradés de la police qui se défend de
cibler les médias lors d'une conférence
de presse pour expliquer l'opération
depuis la vague de manifestations pro
démocratie lit à deux ans la chine veut
consolider son emprise sur hong kong un
ancien territoire britannique qui lui a
été rétrocédé la répression s'est
accentuée
une centaine de militants ont été
arrêtés sous le coup d'une nouvelle loi
protégeant la sécurité nationale
les fermetures de sites et news s'ajoute
à celle du apple daily un quotidien
critique du régime chinois qui était lui
aussi dans la mire des autorités
il a été primé pour la dernière fois en
juin dernier
ça veut dire comme se retrouvent
maintenant sans média indépendant du
gouvernement dénonçait directrice qu'un
groupe canadien qui est puis le
mouvement pro démocratie une canadienne
se retrouvent d'ailleurs parmi les
personnes arrêtées lors de l'opération
contre stay news la chanteuse et
militante denisot qui a déjà résidé à
montréal voici ce qu'elle disait en
juillet 2019
nous sommes tous en danger à hong kong
nous sommes sur le point de devenir une
autre ville chinoise où nous perdrons
tout notre liberté d'expression
nous espérons que le gouvernement
fédéral viendra en aide à denise dit
elle son groupe craint que des canadiens
vivant à hong kong ne soit plus en
sécurité ici olivier bastin réseau
canada montréal